was rogan the guy that told you to stop
fighting and yeah
really what was that what was that
conversation like that was i i was a fan
as a fan of both his and as a fan of
rogans that was one of the more awkward
podcasts i ever listened to what was it
what did he say
um just he could tell i had one foot in
one foot out and he's 100 right you know
rogan's very you know blunt and up front
obviously the message i think is harsh
to the public
but me and him had have such a good
relationship to me you know the only
thing that was surprising was um
i was going to do me and brian were
going to do a show
and i was like you know kind of
announced my retirement kind of not like
i was on the fence
and uh we're driving a student council
hey rogan wants to do it with us
really he goes yeah but he's going to do
that history
so the people think that was a jre
episode that was actually a fighter in
the kid that was a fireman kid at joe
rogan's studio it was my show but on his
platform oh i didn't know that yeah most
people don't really that was
so
i and i told brian all right dude but i
don't like i don't want to talk about
the fight like you know i'm kind of
messed up from depressed man i want to
talk about it he's not he's not going to
do that we're not going to talk about
the food did you tell joe this or you
told brian this no told brian so i
figured he relayed that uh wait so just
a second back so you had to you had
already decided to hang them up before
that yeah because you know i've been
doing fire in the kit at that point for
about three years yeah and i was you
know starting to receive a good amount
of income from that and
you know it was just i i was busy with
that and then i've always been really
into fashion and like my own merch so
instead of wearing like a tap out shirt
i'd create my own shirt and walk out on
that and then sell it myself online and
then reebok said you're not allowed to
do that anymore and that really made me
retire really
interesting so so so so so you so you
didn't know joe was going to ask you and
talk to you about that i had no clue
yeah but you know as a he gave me a
super solid wow what did he ask you what
was the actual just totally stopped
fighting he was like you can tell you're
one foot in one foot out and you're
gonna get hurt you just called your [ __ ]
out right there yeah off the camera what
happened after camera like this so the
whole time he hugged me okay you know
that's what i we're both pretty carry on
yeah he hugged me it's very obvious i
know that was harsh man but i love you
man the reason i did this because i love
the [ __ ] out of him yeah and he's like
but you can do like what i'm telling you
like you podcasting stand up you can do
this man the fyi
90 of a maybe more can't do that nine
percent be generous yeah yeah that's
what i'm saying they cannot do that so
you there it's like the nba you know
everybody leaves the nba like oh okay
what's this guy going to be doing dude
you don't have the personality to be an
analyst you don't have a personality to
be commentated you got to have the
personality the humor all of that so
brendan he was right yeah
right and then even people think i've
issues with dan i have no issues with
dana if i saw him give him a big hug but
he because him signed that reebok deal
at the time
that gave me the fuel to get to where i
wanted to get so i was so mad at him i
was so mad when he signed that reebok
and dana dana white i'm so mad and we
had a conversation on the phone it did
not go well and uh i just kept calling
call him out on shows but he put a
[ __ ] box of pringles on my shoulder
some people have a chip on their
shoulder i had a [ __ ] pringle box on
my shoulder i was so mad but it gave me
the fuel to get to where i wanted to go
and now that i'm on the outside looking
in
you know i've made it this far i would
give him a hug and like thank god you
did that man like i owe all my stuff to
him man you channeled that rage
artistically too which is like that i
mean that's something that because i
didn't want to be a failure not i wasn't
doing to prove to dana like told you i
could do it but i just didn't want to be
that guy that left the ufc and then you
know was [ __ ] holding mitts at the
ufc sure well i meant that they would
scoff in that year too like what are you
going to do oh dude i'm i'm going to do
stand up yeah say that again you're a
big fan of uh dana white though i'm a
big fan very highly i actually want to
ask him a question
i want to be very clear i'm a very big
fan of daniel it's very obvious you made
no issues so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you